you call this framework offensive
realism C can you just give a overview
of the history of the realism versus
liberalism debate as World Views well I
think for many centuries now the big
divide uh within the world of
international relations
theory is between realism and liberalism
these are Tim honored bodies of theory
and before I tell you what I think the
differences are between those two bodies
of theory it is important to emphasize
that there are differences among
realists and differences among
liberals um and so when you talk about
me as an offensive realist you should
understand that there are also defensive
realists out there and there are uh a
panoply of liberal theor iies as well
but uh basically realists believe that
power matters that states compete for
power and that war is an instrument of
statecraft and uh uh liberals on the
other hand have what I would say is a
more idealistic view of the world uh
this is not to say that they're naive or
foolish but they believe there are ass
ects of international
politics uh that lead to a less
competitive and more peaceful world than
most realists see uh and I'll lay out
for you very quickly what are the three
major liberal theories today that I
think will give you a sense of the more
optimistic perspective that is inherent
in the liberal
Enterprise uh the first and most
important of the liberal theories is
democratic peace Theory and this is a
theory that says democracies do not
fight against other
democracies so the more the world is
populated with democracies the less
likely it is that we will have
wars uh and this basic argument is
inherent in Francis fukiyama is the end
of History he argues that democracy
triumphed first over fascism in the 20th
century it then triumphed over communism
and that means that in the future we're
have more and more liberal democracies
on the planet and if you have more and
more liberal democracies and those
democracies don't fight each other then
you have a more peaceful world that was
his argument it's a very liberal
argument a realist like me would say
that it doesn't matter whether a state
is a democracy or not all states behave
the same way because the structure of
the system getting back to our earlier
discussion about International Anarchy
the structure of the system leaves those
States no choice whether they're
democracies or autocracies and again the
liberal view this first liberal theory
is that democracies don't fight other
democracies and therefore the more
democracies you have the more peaceful
the world can I just uh sort of try to
unpack that a little bit so on the
Democratic peace Theory I guess would
say that in democracies leaders are
elected and the underlying assumption is
most people want peace and so they will
elect peacemakers so the more you
democracies you have the more likely you
have peace and then the realist
perspective what says that it doesn't
matter if the majority of people want
peace the
structure of international politics is
such that superpowers want to become
more Super and powerful and they do that
through War you can't make that argument
that you're making about democracies
because if you're saying that
democracies are inclined toward peace
and that the electorate picks leaders
who are inclined towards peace then you
have to show that democracies are in
General more peaceful than
non-democracies and you can't support
that argument you can find lots of
evidence to support the argument that
democracies don't fight other
democracies so the argument I believe
that you have to make if you're going to
support Democratic peace Theory the main
argument you have to make
is that liberal
democracies have a healthy respect for
each other and they can assess each
other's intentions if you're a liberal
democracy and I'm a liberal democracy we
know we have value systems that argue
against aggression and argue for
peaceful resolution of Crisis and
therefore given these Norms we can trust
each other we can know each other's
intentions remember for realists like me
uncertainty about intentions really
helps Drive the train but if you're
talking about two
democracies right the argument there is
that they know each other's intentions
and for you sure maybe democracies
reduce uncertainty a little bit but not
enough to stop the train I think that's
right yeah that's that's right so that's
Democratic peace theory yes the second
theory is economic interdependence
Theory and that's the argument that in a
globalized world like the one that we
live in and have lived in for long a
long time there's a great deal of
economic interdependence and if you and
I are two
countries uh or if you and me are two
countries and we're economically
interdependent and we're both getting
prosperous as a result of this economic
intercourse the last thing that we're
going to do is start a war either one of
us because who would kill the goose that
lays the golden eggs it's that kind of
argument so there you have an argument
that economic interdependence leads to
peace and then the Third liberal
argument has to do with
institutions uh sometimes referred to as
liberal institutionalism and this is the
argument that if you can get States into
institutions where they become rule
abiding
actors they will obey the rules that
dictate that war is not
acceptable uh so if you get them to
accept uh uh the UN rules on when you
can and cannot initiate a war uh then
you'll have a more peaceful world so
those are the liberal theories and as
you can tell they're very different from
realism as articulated by somebody like
may can you uh maybe argue against the
economic interdependence and in the
institutions that institutions follow
rules um a little bit so the the the
Golden Goose with the golden egg
you're saying that nations are happy to
kill the goose because again they want
Power if they think it's necessary to
kill the Golden Goose yeah because of
security concerns they will do it the
point is that economic
interdependence at its root has
Prosperity as the core variable yeah in
the realist story story The Core
variable is survival and survival always
trumps
Prosperity so if you go back to the
period before World War I we're in
Europe it's
1913 or early
1914 what you see is that you have an
intense security competition between all
of the great powers on one side you have
the Triple Alliance and on the other
side you have the triple onon you have
these two alliances and you have an
intense security competition between
them okay at the same time you have a
great deal of economic interdependence
it's amazing how much economic
intercourse is taking place in Europe
among all the actors right and people
are getting prosperous or countries are
getting prosperous as a result but
nevertheless in the famous July crisis
of
1914 this economic prosperity is unable
to prevent World War I because security
concerns or survival is more important
uh so there are you know going to be
lots of situations where prosperity and
survival come into conflict and in those
cases survival will win and uh maybe you
can speak to the different camps of
realists you said offensive and
defensive can you draw a distinction
between those two yeah let me just back
up a bit on that one and you were
talking about Will To Power before uh
the first big
divide between realists is structural
realists and human nature realists nice
and Hans
morganth who was influenced by nature
and
therefore had that willto power logic
embedded in his thinking about how the
world works right he was a human nature
realist okay I'm a structural
realist and I believe it's not human
nature it's it's not individuals and
some Will To Power that drives
competition and War what drives
competition in war is the structure of
the system it's Anarchy so you're not as
romantic as the human nature realists
yeah there's just a a world of
difference between the two sure it's
just important to understand that so
within that from the structural that
there's a subdivision also of offensive
and defensive yes inside the structural
realist world right and you
have a handful of realists who believe
that the structure of the
system Fosters competition for sure
security competition but it really rules
out great power or War almost all the
time
so it makes sense to care about the
balance of power but to focus on
maintaining how much power you have
that's the defense of realism
maintaining how much power you have not
trying to gain more power because the
argument the defensive realists make is
that if you try to gain more power the
system will punish you the structure
will punish you
I'm not a defensive realist I'm an
offensive realist and my argument is
that states look for
opportunities to gain more power and
every time they see or almost every time
they see an opportunity to gain more
power U and they think the likelihood of
success is high and the cost will not be
great they'll jump at that
opportunity